hello everyone
and welcome to today's live broadcast
deep immune profiling of peripheral
blood mononuclear cells
pbmcs with the codex platform
my name is christy jewell of labrutz and
i'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by labyrinth
and sponsored by akoya biosciences
as the spatial biology company akoya
biosciences history
represents the rapid advancement driving
the field of multiplex
biomarker analysis and
immunofluorescence tissue analysis
akoya's portfolio includes the codex
platform
for deep immune profiling and biomarker
discovery
and the phenoptics platform with the
vector scanners
and opal panels for translational and
clinical research
for more information on our sponsor
please visit akoyabio.com
now let's get started i would like to
remind everyone that today's event
is interactive and we encourage you to
participate
by submitting as many questions as you
want in any time you want during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click send also please notice you
can share this webinar on your personal
social media
just click on that social sharing tab on
the left to let your friends and
colleagues know
about today's live event
now if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation
click on that support tab found at the
top of your presentation window
or you can report your problem by
clicking on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
this presentation
is educational and thus offers
continuing education credits just click
on that continuing education credits tab
located at the top right of your
presentation window and follow the
process
to obtain your credits
i would now like to introduce our first
presenter
dr oliver browback senior application
scientist
akoya biosciences dr browback received
his doctorate
from dalhousie university in 2011
he then completed postdoctoral
appointments at yale
and the korea institute of science and
technology
during this time he used
state-of-the-art optical imaging
and optogenetic technologies to
investigate
the structure and function of the
nervous system
oliver's most recent academic
appointment was at cedar sinai
where he conducted research in line with
his background in optical imaging
it was during that time that oliver
started to use the codex system
and decided to follow his excitement for
highly multiplex imaging
by joining akoya for a complete
biography on dr browback
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
welcome dr browback you may now begin
your presentation
hello everybody and thanks for joining
today i'd like to speak to you about the
codex system and in particular what we
would like to do
is to tell you about the diversity of
the applications for this system
the codex system was launched in 2019 by
akoya biosciences
and at that time already it was awarded
the award
on award for one of the top 10
innovations by the scientist magazine
so we're very proud to present this
system to you and speak to you about one
particular application
today deep multiplexing and space
profiling are on vogue today we know
today that
highly multiplexed analyses of tissues
is crucial to understanding how an organ
works
or how a disease progresses or forms but
one of the things that's a little bit
more new
and really being appreciated is the
spatial component of
it so you can see here on the bottom
left
this piece of lung cancer that was
highly multiplexed
image with codex system breast cancer
skin tissues these types of tissues any
type of tissue really
has many many biomarkers in it and it's
absolutely crucial i understand
what these biomarkers are doing and also
where they are
and therefore a pragmatic solution like
the codex system
is very very exciting scientific
development towards understanding
the makeup of these systems but also the
function of these systems
and eventually the dysfunction of these
systems and what we're going to do today
is a little bit different
we're actually not going to talk about
spatial biology we're going to talk
about using the codex systems
to image pvmcs pbmcs are cell suspension
inherently don't really have any spatial
organization but what we would like to
show you here
is that this system is so widely
deployable that you can actually
analyze cell suspensions with it so
we're very excited about this pbmc
application
and with that i would like to turn it
over to
john mon holland and hanum khan both
from stanford university
who developed the protocol for the pbmc
imaging
and who wrote it up and will have made
it available to the codex community at
large
so john will move on now and we'll speak
about how he has implemented the codex
system
in his imaging core and anum will then
speak about how the experiment is
conducted
i will rejoin later to talk about the
data analysis
thank you thank you dr browback
i would now like to introduce our next
presenter john mulholland
director of cell sciences imaging
facility stanford university
john train is a cell biologist and
microscopist while working for 15 years
in the laboratory of dr david
botstein starting at mit then genentech
incorporated
and finally stanford university he has
been director of the beckham center's
cell sciences imaging facility
csif at standard university since 2001.
during that time he has overseen
significant expansion
by establishing its electron microscopy
core expanding components
of its confocal and two photon
microscopy services
as well as adding slim super resolution
imaging instrumentation
and lattice light sheet microscopy
in 2019 with support from stanford
school of medicine
and the stanford cancer institute he
established codex
highly multiplexed imaging services in
the facility
for a complete biography on john please
visit the biography tab
at the top of your screen welcome john
you may now begin your presentation
well thank you everyone for joining us
today my part of the webinar will
discuss the need for highly multiplex
spatial
imaging introduce the codex technology
and then i'll discuss its implementation
in our facility here at stanford let me
first tell you just a little bit about
our facility the cell science imaging
facility
our facility has historically been
focused on providing high-resolution
multi-dimensional imaging technologies
to researchers both here
at stanford as well as outside of
stanford this is done
in three interdependent cores the
fluorescent microscopy core
the electron microscopy core and our new
spatial
multiplexing core it is important to
note i think
that we are not a histology or pathology
lab
and those services are provided by other
university cores
so providing highly multiplex spatial
imaging of tissue and cell suspensions
is a totally new service for us
as you can see in this slide our spatial
multiplexing core offers two
multiplexing services
the array tomography and the codex array
tomography faces
all the known challenges which we're
going to discuss
today of traditional serial
immunofluorescence methods
it offers relatively low plex tissue
imaging on plastic
embedded tissue that is serially
sectioned
as an array onto cover glass and then
subjected to iterative
immunofluorescence imaging that's three
antibodies at a time plus a dappy
channel
array tomography sections though can be
cut as thin as 40 to 50 nanometers
and thus can achieve super resolution in
the z dimension which makes this
technique a little bit unique
on the other hand codecs which we have
now been working with for about a year
or so
avoids many of the challenges faced by
ray tomography and other traditional
serial imf
methods and offers highly multiplexed
imaging
on a single tissue slice at cellular
resolution
so is there a need for multiplex imaging
and what specifically is that need
this graph assembled from pubmed
searches shows a steep rise in the
number of publications
using multiplex imaging over the last
decade
so clearly multiplex imaging is a
growing technique
and is meeting an increasing need but
what is
our need as researchers for multiplexing
and more specifically high or even
ultra high multiplexing
what we need is to label large numbers
of markers over whole tissue slices for
spatial coordinate information
along with intensity measurements we
need low cost
no spectral overlap adequate dynamic
range
and single cell or better resolution
importantly we also need analytical
tools
compared comparable to those employed by
cell sorting
image mass spec and other high plex
technologies
so with that with those applications we
can
map epitope presence along with
intensity as shown in figure a here
segment out single cells and assign in
cluster functional states based on
coincident
epitopes as shown in figure b and then
as illustrated in figure c
explore those functional states in the
context of cell neighborhoods and
cellular niche
but there are challenges to doing all
that
with traditional serial
immunofluorescence methodologies
as we are all familiar with due to
issues of species cross reactivity and
spectral bleed through
we typically limited to three probes per
cycle
then there are problems inherent in
removing the sample from the slide
stripping and reprobing and again
imaging for each successive round of
three to four antibodies
then post image acquisition there are
the issues of overlying
overlaying and aligning of images for
each successive round of probing and
imaging
one solution to avoid the problems
inherent in immunofluorescent methods
altogether and
to instead is to instead use mass-based
metal reporters such as
in conjunction with imaging mass
cytometry and multiplexed ion beam
imaging better known as midi this allows
for potentially greater than 100 probes
per assay
straightforward panel design no
autofluorescence a dynamic
range order of magnitudes over
immunofluorescence
no stripping and high resolution is
achievable depending on the beam
diameter
but this requires expensive equipment
and reagents
and complicated technology requiring a
high degree of expertise to operate
additionally there's sample destruction
and finally there just isn't many
accessible instruments available
particularly in shared
core facilities a more familiar approach
which requires far less expensive
instrumentation and expertise
and costs far less is to use the codex
approach
codex was the devil developed several
years ago in gary nolan's lab as
oliver has pointed out and as you know
that that technology has since been
commercialized by akoya
similar to traditional serial immuno
fluorescent techniques codex uses
iterative rounds of staining and imaging
as you can see schematically here
but in contrast the primary antibodies
are applied to the tissue slice
altogether
as a panel in a single step and then the
tissue is repeatedly probed in image
reporters as demonstrated here
so how does this work well specifically
let's take a look at the chemistry
the basic chemistry of codex is
relatively simple each antibody in an
antibody panel
which can be up to 40 antibodies is
conjugated in a
to a unique oligonucleotide barcode the
entire antibody panel is then applied to
the tissue in a single step
the stained tissue slide is then mounted
on the microscope's codex microfluidics
platform after that
fluoresce the four floor coupled oligo
reporters that are complementary to the
oligos the antibody oligos barcode are
applied three colors at a time
and the three individual fluorescent
channels are then imaged as indicated in
this slide
so again here we see the codex workflow
where the antibody panel stains the
tissue all in one step
the tissue now on the microscope is then
probed with
a set of three complementary oligo
reporters to reveal specific markers
the tissue is then imaged three reported
channels at a time
plus dappy here we see just the first
cycle
then still on the microscope the oligo
reporters are alluded
and we repeat the workflow and sets of
three unique reporters plus adapting
importantly this is all automated on the
microscope there's no removal of the
slide until the last round of imaging is
complete
here we're showing 16 plus cycles
so what are the advantages of codex over
other highly multiplied
methodologies well from our experience
in our core
there's there has been no restriction on
antibody host species so panel design is
flexible and simple
the four channels sequential imaging
produces little to no spectral bleed
through
and is done on your familiar
immunofluorescent microscope so there's
no learning of new technologies really
the platform is automated so after the
tissue is labeled with a panel of
antibodies and mounted on the codex
you can pretty much walk away when
needed we can achieve diffraction limit
or resolution for sub-cellular
localization as well
and importantly to us the data is in a
familiar
and third-party compatible file format
the dot fcs
so we see codex so we see in the
facility
codex is an affordable basic science
tool for our core
but it's important to note it's not a
high-throughput tool
and there's other instrumentation out
there in the market for that
okay so in this slide i'm simply
demonstrating the labeling and imaging
quality of a five plex panel plus dappy
on a tissue microwave
array there are good signal noise ratios
in this imaging with high resolution
and this will also be evident in the
data that will be presented on the pbmcs
our next speakers the num and all of it
will also show data from pvmcs with much
higher multiplexing
okay so on this slide i'm basically just
wanting to show
uh what our startup costs were for
starting uh
codex within the facility and as you can
see that the total price of
approximately
230 000 for startup is a very reasonable
cost point for most core facilities
lastly in the csif we offer codex
multiplexing services that include
profiling using the koi's established
screened antibodies and conjugates
profiling aquarius using equations and
community established validated panels
using custom validated antibody
conjugates and panels
and it's important to note that
profiling can be done with fresh frozen
as well as on
ffpe's tissue slices so for more
information about our codec service
and custom conjugation costs etc we can
be contacted at
the your url showed at the bottom there
or at my email
directly i now like to turn the webinar
over to anam khan
who will tell you a little bit about
deep profiling on pbmcs with codex
thank you john our next presenter is dr
anam khan
staff scientist cell sciences imaging
facility
stanford university dr khan came to
stanford
after receiving her doctorate from
dartmouth college in 2018
during her graduate training she used a
variety of microscopy techniques
to investigate how cytoskeletal proteins
called
septins assemble in cells and in vitro
she's currently working on optimizing
the codec service pipeline
as well as collaborating with stanford
researchers on using codex to understand
various biological problems
and disease progression for a complete
biography on dr khan
please visit a biography tab at the top
of your screen
for a complete biography on dr khan
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
welcome dr khan you may now begin your
presentation
thank you christy for the introduction
and thank you everyone for joining us
as mentioned by oliver and john corex
really was developed as a solution to
combine
ultra high multiplexing with spatial
data
needed to understand the tissue
architecture
here we're using codex to demonstrate
its application
on understanding self understanding cell
suspension
and we're using pbmcs as our cell
suspension
model so single cell studies done on
cell suspensions are very important to
understand
a variety of different biological
functions so for example
in order to understand a body's response
to
a foreign pathogen we can use the
cell suspension such as the blood to
understand how a body reacts to it
we can also use cell suspensions to
identify an unknown microbe for example
cell suspensions can also be used to
understand
the underlying cell functions such as
psychophytosis or cell cycle or
apoptosis
of a cell one commonly used
example of cell suspension in a clinical
setup
are tumor biopsies so in a
cartoon shown on the left over here you
can see
that tumors at various stages are
heterologous population of different
tumor cells
so in order to understand how the tumor
progresses
we need to be able to do highly
multiplex
studies on these tumor biopsies to look
at the entire population of cells that
are present within the different
stages and understand disease
progression
another commonly used example of cell
suspensions in a clinical setup is
blood shown on the right over here in
the schematic so for example in a
situation such as the one they're facing
with the highly infectious disease such
as covet 19 these days
we can use blood to understand the
body's
immune response to something infectious
such as the coronavirus
so cell suspensions give us an insight
into how the body is reacting
we can also use blood to understand or
to look at different
calculating molecules that the body
produces in response to these
viruses for example
so here we're using codex as a platform
to understand or to look at one of these
cell suspensions
so what we did i'm deeply going to walk
you through what we did
for this experiment so we took human
pbmcs
they were fixed in solution using 1.6
percent psa
they were then added to a polylysine
coated coverslip
they were then stained on the coverslip
for three hours at room temperature with
26 different antibodies
the excess antibodies were washed off
the cells were fixed again
and then were image using the codex
platform
if somebody is interested in replicating
this protocol in their own labs we do
have a write-up
i'm not going to go into the detail of
each of the steps
but i just wanted to show you briefly
what it looks like and if anyone's
interested in replicating this or
getting access to this protocol you can
either contact me
or akoya at the two email addresses
shown at the bottom of this slide over
here
so in order to do highly multiplexing on
to demonstrate high multiplexing on the
cell suspension
we use a 26 antibody panel so for this
purposes we use a coil validated
antibody panel that they
have used for fresh frozen tissue this
includes a repertoire of different
markers for immune cells including
t cells t cells monocytes etc
we also included two negative markers as
controls highlighted in red over here
and on the right i'm just showing the
seven
seven of the 26 markers seen on the
right hand side in this image
to just show you what these images and
the staining pattern look like i'm going
to show you some of the
markers within this canon in the next
slide over here
so you can see a field of view
in this slide and you i'm going to walk
you through some of the different
markers that we use
i'm not going to go into details but
just to show you what the staining
pattern looks like
and then that we see a strong signal to
noise i'm gonna just walk you through
the different images we see in some of
the different markers
so before i hand it over to oliver to
dive into the
data analysis part of the study we
wanted to do to perform some basic
quality control measures to assess
codec performance on these cbmc so it's
not a given that these cells are gonna
remain adhered onto the coverslip
since the codex involves multiple
washing steps
over multiple cycles it is a possibility
that some of these cells can get washed
away
so on the left here what i'm showing you
is series of images
taken over multiple cycles so you can
see the cycle number going from 1 to
12 and then you're seeing the same
nuclei over these multiple cycles
some of the flicker you see is because
of the frame shift
but we don't see any significant loss or
increase in number of nuclei that we're
seeing in this screen
on the right here we've quantified the
number of nuclei we're seeing
over two different experiments and then
four different imaging
areas so we're looking at a total of
about 80 000 cells
and on the y-axis we have the number of
nuclei
that remain over a 12-cycle
experiment and you can see uh in the red
line shown over here that
for most of the cycles the line remains
black
around 100 of the nuclei take
over the duration of the entire
experiment
we do see some jitter around cycle 5 but
we believe
it is because of some of these cream
shifts more so than any significant loss
of cells
so the what we conclude from here
is that we don't we there's minimal loss
of cells
fixed onto these polylife encoded
coverslips over the duration of
a multi-cycle correct experiment
another thing i wanted to show you was
what kind of cell densities we can get
from such experiments
so here i'm showing you two uh different
experiments two different
densities so on the left is the low
density area on the right is a high
density area so about
1600 cells per millimeter square and on
the
right is twice that much and um just to
point out these are single new images
so assuming the same density throughout
we can calculate
uh for a total in a different area of 15
by 15 millimeter
you can get somewhere around almost 400
or 360 000 cells in a low density
density area such as this one on the
left and around
700 000 cells for a highly dense area
such as the one on the right
it really depends on what your what
numbers you're looking at but we think
both of these tendencies are okay for
any
single cell studies so
and then if we zoom into one of these
highly aggregated
nuclei what you can see here on the left
is that we do see some debris
and this is just part of the experiment
there's not much we can do
in terms of getting rid of the debris
but one thing that can be done
post acquisition is that you could draw
a roy to
exclude areas that include that degree
another thing that we really need to do
is to be able to
segment out these cells to be able to
count them all i was going to go into
detail but i just wanted
to show that even in high density areas
such as the one shown on the right and
these highly
clustered cells our codex algorithm
that oliver is going to talk about
further does a good job of segregating
or segmenting these
nuclei into individual cells
so before i hand it over to oliver i
just wanted to highlight some of the
advantages that one may have by using
codex
for uh studying cell suspension as
opposed to something
that is more commonly used such as a
flow cytometry technique
so for most commonly used close either
millers you can do up to four to eight
different markers
uh whereas a codex allows you to do very
steep or ultra high multiplexing almost
ten times that of the pro cytometer
while
letting you do up to 40 plus markers at
any given time
the second advantage is with slow
cytometer there is a large number of
controls that are involved so for
example some of these controls are
you need to do unstained controls for
each of the markers that you are doing
fluorescence minus one controls these
and these are
just only some of them there are a lot
more on the
with the codex on the other hand you can
get away with
a limited number of controls and this is
because
as opposed to a flow cylo meter in a
codex you do have the ability to
visualize your cell morphology
as well as to look at the localization
of a certain marker within the cell
so with that i'm gonna hand it over to
oliver who's gonna go into further
detail of the analysis
that was done on pbmc thank you
okay thank you anum and also thank you
john from the great presentations and
especially for making this experiment
happen
i think this is super exciting and i'm
going to talk to you about
some analysis that we did at akoya
what's the data that john and hanum have
provided
so first off i would like to tell you
that um we have an
end-to-end software solution to analyze
these data
and everything that you will see today
coming out of me and the
end of this seminar will be done with um
software that's provided with codex
so we have a codex instrument manager
this is what you use to control your
microscope your light source
set up the tiling essentially to acquire
the imaging data
that is collected as part of a codex
experiment
then we have a codex processor and this
is a really
big part really important part for any
lab that
for example doesn't have access to a
bioinformatician because this processor
will do drift compensation background
subtraction deconvolution
cell segmentation a lot of functions
that are pretty nifty and very very
useful
and then lastly we have the codex
multiplex analysis viewer or math
which is the platform that we use to do
the actual data analysis
and that is a platform that will that i
use to generate all of the data that i
will show you now
this software is based on imagej plugin
so it's available right now you can
download it you can install it on your
computer all for free
and it's very good actually it combines
imaging data
with some very higher level functions
like gating t-sne
plotting k-means clustering spatial
interaction analysis
all of this can be done inside of the
mass
and i'm going to show you some of these
outputs right now
so as anum had said the principle of our
analysis
the way we get to converting imaging to
numerical data
is by a cell segmentation so here you
can see a bunch of nuclei
and here is the actual segmented output
this is a rather dense region of your
coverslip you can see it does a pretty
good job
the output here in tabular form you can
see
every cell has an id in this particular
case there were 35 000 cells
and then every cell has a multiplex
labeling pattern shown by ab1 that's an
antibody one
and so on and so forth so antibodies can
be very
labeling either very strongly which is
here you can see 48 000 that would be a
pretty strong signal
versus very weakly which is 394 which
was essentially a blank
and if you think about it in this
particular example you have 36
antibodies
over 35 000 cells it's an incredibly
complex grid
of data so what we have is we have an
fcs and csv output
that is readily generated by math so for
those of you who are bioinformaticians
in your lab or
are bioinformaticians you can take these
files and put them in
any platform that you like for those of
you who would
use our software for their data analysis
you'll be working with math and i'm
going to show you once again
some of the things that you can do with
this so first off i would like to show
you that we have some very nice built-in
quality control functions so you can see
this here
this is blue square here this blue
rectangle actually sorry
this shows you imaging data from two
regions
in one experiment each one of these
histograms works as follows
you have from left to right the labeling
intensity or the fluorescent intensity
of the cd45 antibody
so the further over to the right it is
the more intensely
labels over on the left side it's a
blank
on the y-axis you have the frequency of
cells that are located anywhere along
this intensity spectrum
so for cd45 for example you can see
there are very few
cells sitting around on the left edge
that means there's very few
weakly labeled cells whereas over here
you have high frequency of cells that
are labeled very nicely with cd45
this is precisely the result you want to
see in a quality control for pvmcs
because by definition these cells should
be cd4
positive but what we do would like what
we would like
to show you especially here is that this
gives you sort of a snapshot overview of
your data quality
and for that let's focus on the second
column here
so in the second column you have cd3
labeling cd3 labels t
cells in this particular experiment up
here two different regions
you see this sort of dual spike
histogram lots of cells
in the low intensity regions lots of
cells in the high intensity regions
these will be your blanks this is what
you will cut out as i will show you in a
second
and these are your actual positive
staining results now if you go down the
experiment number two
you can see just a single skinny peak
it's all hovering around the lower
intensity region
so you would know right off the bat
there could be something wrong with this
experiment
maybe the antibody didn't label properly
or maybe the antibody that the user has
chosen this particular regard
is not ideal for the per for the
particular application
this is um one thing i would like to
bring up here is because again
we like to reiterate this the user can
choose the antibody that they would like
to use
so if this antibody for this particular
application is not ideal
you can go back you can find a better
cd3 antibody
reconjugate it and use it for your codex
experiment
so this quality control is very good get
a first look of your data
if you're happy with your data you go on
and you actually do some analysis
within mav we have built-in gating
functions and they allow you to sort
your data rather seamlessly
so if you have used code flow cytometry
currently or in the past you will
probably know what this is
this is a scatter plot in which you can
see background fluorescence on your
x-axis and cd3 fluorescence on your
y-axis
each dot is a cell if you consider this
small little dot here
you can see it's very high in background
fluorescence very low in cd3
fluorescence
it's probably some type of debris if you
look at this dot over here
very high in cd3 fluorescence very low
in background fluorescence
that's probably a very clean t cell so
what we do
and what you do for example in flow
cytometry is you do gating
you really draw a manual gate about
around a whole bunch of these cells
and then you determine whether or not
these are indeed cells
so with math with codex this is very
easy to do
because you can draw a gate and you get
instant visual feedback
so here you can see this black gay i
just chose a small region of interest
in the image viewer and you can see each
one of these
is a t cell likewise if you draw this
yellow gate
you can see here there are a whole bunch
of dots in here they could be cells
you don't really know until you have
visual feedback you can actually see
that these are all false positives
so this is one of the things that i
particularly believe are the strengths
of doing this kind of an experiment with
math is because you get
instant feedback you can see this is a
true signal
this is a false positive this is
immensely useful
very interactive a very exciting way to
actually do gating
so now you've identified your cd3 cells
you can gate these particular cells once
more
and you can interrogate and you can say
which one of my cd3 cells contains cd4
t-rex a subtitle of t cell once again
you get a distinct distribution in your
scatter plot you draw your gate
and you will get visual confirmation of
say these red cells
these red cells are your cd3 cd4 t-rex
do this again you can do the same thing
with cda
draw another gate again you're looking
at these mcd3 cells
and then you can see all of the
different cell types together
once again you have visual confirmation
and it's very interactive tool to work
with
now what i would like to show you in
this next slide is a proof of principle
from where we basically show you that
this experiment works
as it should work based on reference
values
up here you can see five different types
of cells
you have three t cell types 83 cd4 cda
positive ones
there's a b cell type and there are stem
cells each one is shown in a different
color
down below are histograms now these
histograms have two data points in them
first of all there's a dashed line the
dashed line is your reference value
that's what we would expect these cells
to be like from clinical reference
guides
and from the atlas of hemopathology
that's what we
use to determine these values so this is
where you would want your t cell
proportions to be
each one of these dots black or colored
is an experiment that we did
using the codex system with pvmcs you
can see that
almost every experiment falls within the
range so this is a very nice
confirmation that your coded data are
consistent with reference values
and that indeed you can use this
experiment to analyze
pvmc immune profiles
now one thing i would like to point out
is because
we're talking about data and different
tools if you look at the cda result you
can actually see that there's one
experiment that falls outside of the
expected range
so you could right-clock this experiment
you could say oh there's something wrong
with the patient or
what kinds of ideas that you can get out
of it but remember
we have all kinds of different types of
data available this case
you can go back to your cda quality
control data and you can look at the
histograms you can look at the frequency
distributions of your intensity signals
here you will recognize that for these
top two dots
you will have this bimodal intensity
distribution
especially here you have a lot of cda
cells that have high intensity
if you look at the second experiment
it's just just one peak
that's sort of mid-range to low intense
intensity fluorescence cd8 staining
so i as a researcher would now conclude
well maybe this
was not ideal staining maybe his
antibody was not the right one
something is wrong with this experiment
rather than there being something wrong
with the patient
so this is an example of not only
the tools that you have but that you can
use our school
codex system to analyze pbmcs
so now i'm going to switch gears a
little bit and i'm going to go into the
really deep multiplexing aspect of this
a gnome has already shown this slide
where essentially here you can see a
whole bunch of different pmcs
with five different labels let me switch
over
you see same field of view but different
pdmcs with another six labels
here are another seven labels here are
another five labels
all told this pattern is this result
these data
are very very complex you have 20 000
cells
you have 26 unique reporter readouts if
you were going to manually date
all of these cells manually analyze all
of these cells it will take you hours
days
weeks now if not months it's very
difficult to do this manually
so what we'd like to show you now is
that you can actually do all of this via
k-means clustering
and unsupervised organization of the
data
in math so this function this clustering
of data
into distinct groups into distinct
phenotypic um proportions
can be done within the math software
and that is what this looks like when
you do it so what you can see here
is a result in which i've done unbiased
k-means clustering
for one sample example number one you
can see on the left-hand side
is a heat map this heat map summarizes
the antibody labeling
for each one of the 26 antibodies this
is the result
that anum has done had created for us
i've done the analysis for it
so every antibodies listed down here and
then there are cell types here
the heat map is coded where red is hot
that means an antibody stains strongly
blue is cold antibodies trains weekly
so the clustering algorithm has
identified i think
14 different cell types once that
happens you have to manually curate your
list
you have to go through the list you have
to annotate your
cell types based on what you know from
the literature so we know that a b cell
for example
labels with cd19 you can see here
two cell types are labeled with cd19
those are your b
cells the same is for your t cells for
your precursor cells
and for your circulating epithelial
cells
um the manual curation involves a little
bit of filtering your data
and cleaning it up because clustering
algorithms tend to overdo it
so they will always identify more types
of cells that
really are there so the user has to know
or has to be somewhat familiar with the
biology of the system
because you do have to curate your data
but all told
we have about 12 different types of
cells on this heat map
you can see here the numbers of these
cells they're shown in this histogram
blue b cells green you have key regs
and in this color here you have
macrophage precursors
and other cells are assigned in black to
the right hand side you have a tissue
plot
statistic plot basically shows you every
single cell
as being a little dot here's an example
of a single cell
and these dots are then grouped by color
and positioned
into distinct phenotypic populations so
you can see the color coding of this
disney plot
correlates with this histogram and these
are the names of the cells
you can see the t regs are the most
prominent population in this
pbmc sample as are these gm precursors
so the question now is this is exciting
this is good
you've identified 12 different
phenotypes based on unbiased clustering
this is really good
because it's a relatively hands-off
approach and
it is very deep immune profiling so now
let's ask how consistent is this
resolved
and i'm now going to switch my slide
over and you will probably barely notice
a difference because these results are
really similar so here we go
the slide switch is over now you can see
and i'll go back
just to show you the heat maps they
change a little bit but non-drastically
and that's really nice because it shows
you that the question algorithm
now once again we're doing unbiased
k-means clustering for sample number two
it's very consistent this time we're
finding 11 cell types so we're actually
missing one cell type
that we have found before but everything
else is very much in line with it
we got our b cells our t cells we got
our precursor cells and others
this is the disney plot now i'm going to
put these two data
side by side and you can see this a
little bit better
so what i would like to show you on this
side is the consistency of clustering
data
again we're speaking about deep
phenotyping deep immune cell phenotyping
in a pbmc sample
hasn't been tried before this is no
experiment consistency is key
so here you can see two testing plots
you get your sample one on the top
and two on the bottom now with
clustering and these kinds of
representations
every result will look different you'll
never achieve the same geography
for example this green area here it's
here in this particular plot
over here in this particular plot that's
the nature of
how these results are generated what's
important to recognize is
is that you have the approximate shapes
and sizes of these patterns
are similar for example here you have b
cells
you can see they're almost exactly the
same in the other experiment
i've broken this down in a different way
over here on the right hand side
this is your cell phenotype summary
where we're showing the percentage
of the total cell population for each
one of these identified immune cell
types
color-coded by cell type you're going
from zero percent
to a hundred percent and you can see
that the breakdown
you're color-coded once again it's
almost identical
you got lots of t-rex you know a lot of
these precursor cells
and then smaller proportions of cda t
cells
and other types of b cells so the 11
cell phenotypes that we've now
identified in this experiment
they're represented in different
clustering results to a very similar
degree
they're proportionally consistent
meaning that we find the same amounts of
the same different immune cell types
across different samples
and this leads us to conclude that codex
with a map analysis produces consistent
deep immune profiling of pbmcs
now i'm going to circle back right to
where we began in my last section here
which was the manual analysis of these
data
you may remember remember this slide
this is the output that we got
from manually gating immune cells in a
pbmc sample you get your cd8
cm cd3 cells cd4 cells and so on and so
forth
these dots are different experiments and
they fall within the reference values
that we expect
this is what we've done manually and i
have to say i did this analysis
it took a fair bit of time now
i've overlapped the clustered results on
our manual results
so rather than having dots to represent
individual experiments
we now have bars and you can see here m1
that was my manual analysis one i gave
it for a single marker
cd3 m2 i did it again manual two
c1 and c2 is my clustered result
but this time i don't just have
information about just one marker
i actually am able to resolve four
different markers within this cd3
population
the same holds true for example if you
look over to the right hand side
here i manually gated these cells i was
very happy
they fell within the reference value
makes sense experiment works
good stuff but if you look at the
cluster result you can actually see oh
there are two types of cp cells now
one is hla negative one is hla positive
i didn't really pay attention to that in
the beginning i wasn't specifically
looking for it
but my analysis the unbiased clustering
led me there right now
and i am now aware of the fact that
these two cell types are actually here
one last thing i would like to say about
this is in manual analysis
the low plex identification of four cell
types that you see here
took me about the same time as it took
me to do the clustered analysis
where i have 12 different cell types so
i think this is a very nice example
of deep immune profile pvcs using codex
as an
experimental platform and math as an
analytical platform
so to summarize what the three of us
have talked about today
i'd like to show you this little
animation it looks like christmas lights
but in reality
what we're doing here we're doing codex
imaging of cell suspensions
we're sorting and manually and we're
using unbiased clustering and math to
really make sense of what these
different types of cells are
and we're reconfirming that these
findings that we have
are in line with what is expected from
the literature
so this is a good example of deep immune
profiling of pbmcs
now let's put this into some perspective
um everybody probably knows what this is
today we didn't know this few months ago
but kovac 19
is everywhere today and we are all aware
of it
and we're all we're all in we're all in
awe or maybe
scared of this and it's very very
hot or very very important today in
science
to understand what this virus is doing
to human health
so there's a huge push for immune
profiling
patient stratification but also tissue
analysis
that um in in samples or in patients
that are suffering from this terrible
condition
and so we think that there are diverse
needs
for deep immune profiling and immune
profiling of pbmcs
is being done almost on a daily basis
now today
in view of this condition and we hope
that what we've shown you today
will allow you to think about this a
little bit more and hopefully will allow
people to
use this tool and make some progress
towards identifying
solutions not only to this problem but
many others
that are associated with our health so
with that i'd like to thank you for
watching
on behalf of everyone who participated
here and i would also ask you to join us
again on may 12th
at the virtual aquaria academy since
we're all at home
we're going to keep this going and we're
going to talk about how to analyze pvmc
data with mav
so we're going to do a very much more
detailed
overview of the analysis that i've shown
you today
which buttons to click which which
functions to use
so that you can actually replicate this
kind of um analysis with your own
results
so if you want more information about
this go to akoyabio.com
virtual events and we'll see you then
thank you very much
thank you dr browback and welcome back
john and dr khan
we will now start the lie now q a
portion of our webinar
now to our audience if you have a
question you would like to ask please do
so now
just click on that ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we will answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
okay let's get started we have so many
great questions already coming in
all right let's start with this one
is field of view to be kept constant
throughout the process
um hi um thanks for the question yeah so
the field of view
is kept constant throughout the imaging
process
initially what the user does they define
their field of view
so feel the views being where your lens
see something
but then you can expand your field of
view by tiling into
adjacent field of views all of this is
registered
in 2 and 3d um by the
computer by the acquisition software and
we find that there's very little shift
of frame
throughout all of the imaging cycles
that we've done
and we've tried this up to 20 or more
cycles
so we find very high consistency in the
field of view
especially in 2d and one last thing to
mention here is that for every field of
view
we acquire multiple um focal planes
which allows us to reconstruct small
shifts small frame shifts into c
dimensions as well
thank you
thank you dr browback our next question
it is my understanding uh let's see
it is my understanding that only cell
surface protein markers can be
captured and not proteins within the
cells
um hi there um so i think that your
understanding on this is not quite
correct
so it's true that most of the markers
that we have tested and most of the
markers that are
currently well established in our
experiment are
cluster differentiation markers for
example these would be mainly located on
the cell membrane
however we do know that we can capture
proteins and
cells in uh sorry proteins and
other molecules inside of the cells so
our system
antibody labeling penetrates the cell
membranes and recognizes intracellular
targets and
epitopes so as an example for example um
for this particular experiment we label
ki-67
which is an intracellular molecule we've
also established labeling for other
markers such as pcna and fox p3
all of these are intracellular or
nuclear markers
so it is indeed possible to not only
label markers on the cell membrane
but also to recognize intracellular
targets
thanks again
and thank you our next question hello
great presentation this question is for
john
is codex a single step staining protocol
and would it be affected by the affinity
of the antibodies
okay thank you for the question uh yes
the primary antibodies are all done as a
single step staining protocol
this can be done overnight if if the
affinity antibodies low we can do it
overnight at four degrees if necessary
but it is all done
the primary antibodies are all done in a
single step
off the microscope and if you're worried
about
the number of antibodies going on in
steric hindrance we haven't bumped into
that at all
yet so i don't think it will be a
problem so hope that answers the
question
thank you thank you john
our next question and dr browback i
believe this one's for you
are more narrow wavelength gatings
available
to reduce the cycling numbers
um this is a good question and in
principle
yes the answer will be yes but at the
moment
um we are using a sci-5 um
ato 550 and af488 um as our fluorescent
markers these have relatively
broad shoulders or some some degree of
overlap in their fluorescent
um emission excitation spectra so it is
true that
probably we could um increase the cycle
or decrease the cycle numbers and
increase the load of different
fluorescent markers per
cycle if we switched our fluorophores at
this point we have done that yet
so um we are working with those three
markers um remember this is also a tool
for um
spatial analysis meaning that our
primary user uses this in
in tissues that are say for example ffpe
formal and fixed this limits the
scope of trying to um you know
load up individual cycles with as many
fluorophores as possible because we are
dealing with autofluorescence as well
so i think the in principle the answer
to your question is yes but this is a
user by user decided option
we actually find that most users tend to
increase the number of cycles just to
get
optimal spectra spectral separation of
their fluorophores
so this is sort of a a bimodal um
answer here but really comes down to the
user
what we can offer for sure right now is
we have sci-fi
af488 as750
and ato 550 and that's what we have and
so the user can
mix and match these fluorophores as they
please depending on whatever application
there is
thank you thank you dr browback
dr khan let's come to you for this next
question
these set of proteins detected were all
cell surface proteins correct
and can the system detect proteins that
were secreted
such as cytokines
so for most of the markers that we
showed we didn't go into detail but most
of them were cell surface markers but we
did have intracellular
such as a nuclear marker that oliver
mentioned earlier we did have a ki-67
um and some of the validated panels we
do have the ability to detect
intracellular proteins
however currently we don't have the
ability to detect
uh secreted proteins such as cytokines
um and
i don't i don't believe we would be able
to see them with pbmcs anyways
but no we don't we cannot detect
cytokines currently
thank you dr khan john let's come to you
for this question
are there antibody panels for codex
platform analysis available for
species other than human canine feline
bovine porcine
who was that directed to john this one's
for you would you like me to repeat the
question
uh no i i got it uh currently no
we don't have any uh antibody panels uh
for the canine feline bovine or porcine
populations species but those
could be i guess done we'd have to do
the conjugations and then do the
check the antibodies etc but there's no
reason not to as far as i can understand
yeah let me dive in here quickly yeah we
so we have established that the system
works from your end
tissue um it works with anti-mouse
antibodies
and it's um just to add here also that
we do have custom conjugation of our
antibodies so we have a large antibody
catalog you can see that on our website
and they're broken down by human ffpe
human ff and mouse i think mouse fresh
frozen
but if a user for example is working on
non-human primates or or corking models
they can test their own antibodies and
conjugate the floor force onto these
antibodies
to see that it works so any antibody out
there
is fair game up until the point that you
screen it
so you can explore whatever organism
you're working with say zebra fish c
elegans we haven't done that we know
human and mouse works
but um the application spectrum and the
different
different species that people are
working with is expanding
thank you
thank you dr browback now we have time
for a few more questions but i do want
to remind our audience that those
questions we are unable to answer
live today and additionally those that
come in during the on-demand period
they will be addressed by our speakers
via the email address you provided
at the time of registration okay let's
take a few more questions
can we use this for three dimensional
imaging
i i think the short answer for that is
oh sorry
go ahead the short answer for that is is
no uh however uh it
in theory is possible um this would be
uh to put the serial sections on there
and then treat each serial section as a
region of interest
and but you'd have to do the alignments
etc off uh
outside of can i just call your software
yeah
i'll add to john uh yeah so the
the data that we're taking is uh we do
do a z
stack um and then take the best focus
out of that
for segmentation if that's what you
meant by a 3d data
so there is a z component to it um
but we we do flatten it out in the end
for further analysis but we use the z
uh stack to pick out the best focal
plane
john did we lose your connection that
got a little
okay our next question
does math only work with codex processor
output
um yes mav only works with the codex
processor output
specifically designed to analyze data
that come out of codecs
very good thank you and our next
question has two parts
to do clustering and phenotype
assignment do we need to purchase
an additional module of math and
how can we access the map access the map
tool
so let's um answer these questions in
reverse
actually how can we access the map tool
so the math or the multiplex analysis
viewer is actually an image
shape plug-in you can download that from
our website and you can install that
onto your image shape platform as a
plugin
simply by sliding the operation into the
plugins folder
and it should work right after so this
is available immediately
you can use it right away and it's free
the second part of this question is to
do the clustering and phenotype
assignment do we need to purchase an
additional module
no you don't it's all built in into math
and the way it comes
on the way you download it and install
it in the image j
it all runs off that platform so you
have
your image viewer with all the built-in
tools from imagej which is quite nice
gives you a lot of different things like
roi selection
level adjustment and whatnot plus you
have these clustering tools
um disney class disney viewers k-means
clustering
essentially everything that i showed in
the seminar today
is built into there so uh if you want to
you can
set this up today um at no cost really
thank you
thank you dr browback now let's go with
this question
can you export the data as a dot fcs
so other tools can be used for data
analysis
absolutely so we have all of our data
converted into tabular from comma
separated values
um so you can export csv fcs files and
they can be readily imported into other
computational platforms of your choice
a lot of our users are doing that so
this is absolutely no problem
dr browback can you answer this next
question for me
how do we sign up for the codex may 12
seminar
ah so that's this good great question
um i'll be there to talk to you so may
12 seminar
all you need to know is go to
akoyabio.com
virtual events and look for the akoya
academy
and click on that button and you follow
through and there's a registration
button that you can click
and just type in your name and your
contact and you're you're good to go
very good thank you and
let's wrap with this final question
um let's see we have so many
actually you know what let's go ahead
and take some final comments
um you know i'm so sorry let's take this
last final question what markers are the
best for
characterizing nk cells
um so that's a great question and
i am a codex user i use a lot of
different applications
full disclosure my background is
actually neuroscience however i do know
that nk
cells are most routinely
visualized with cd56 um so that's a very
standard
nk cell marker i think if you combine it
with cd69 you can actually also
further interrogate activation states so
we did not actually use dd56 in this
particular
experiment but um if you type in
nk cell flow cytometry for example or
any type of detection method generally
people tend towards
cd56 thanks
and thank you i do want to give our
speakers
opportunity to say any final comments
and for me i just want to say thank you
for all our listeners it's great
yeah thank you for signing up and
showing up
yeah absolutely thank you all for being
here especially people
who are in a very different time zone on
a friday night listen to speak
it was an honor and thank you so much
for being here
and hopefully i'll have a good weekend
stay safe out there
and most importantly stay healthy
yes thank you and before we go i do want
to thank our audience for joining us
today also and for their interesting
questions
we had so many questions come in live
today that we were not able to answer
them all
they will be answered via the email
address you provided at the time of
registration
i would like to once again thank john
mulholland dr anam khan and dr oliver
browback for their time today
and for their important research we
would also like to thank lab roots and
our sponsor
akoya biosciences for underwriting
today's educational webcast
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
labyrinths will alert you
via email when it is available for
replay we encourage you to share that
email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
a survey will now pop up on your screen
and we appreciate your feedback
additionally when you finish filling out
the survey you will be redirected to the
registration page
for the upcoming event with okoya the
um akoya academy we hope to see you
there
that's all for now and we thank you for
joining us stay healthy
and have a great day